let's go back to the phones the phone
number is 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 let's go
next it's always scary when we do this
we'll go to a caller from Skype Skype
caller tell us who you are where you're
calling from and what question I can
answer for you today hi yes hopefully
this won't be a terrifying call for you
my name is Pascal LaRue
I'm calling from Ottawa Canada good and
my question is have you been aware of
what has been going on in regards to
lawsuit between 18 States District of
Columbia versus the Trump administration
in regards to the Affordable Care Act
not being not paying out its
cost-sharing reductions I am not what's
going on with it
so uh October 13th there was a lawsuit
that was presented by these 18 states in
the District of Columbia the way I
became aware of it was a gentleman by
the name of Leonard French who is an
attorney yep he does like yeah he does a
presentation on YouTube and he was
reading through this and essentially
what's happening is the Trump
administration is not paying out the
cost-sharing reductions since about that
period of time since like October 13 so
they're trying to in effect tank it so
to speak right yeah this is something
that I've been talking about for a while
which is politically it's a big thing to
repeal the Affordable Care Act
particularly when it's increasingly
ingrained in American society
the way though to kind of make it go
away de-facto is just start pulling
money from it cut subsidies the way
Donald Trump did last week or the week
before don't pay the cost-sharing so
it's I'm not at all surprised Pascal
I've predicted that this was a much more
direct path to Republicans for
Republicans sabotage it and then use the
fact that it's not working because of
your sabotage to justify or mandate its
removal so thanks for letting me know
I'll look more into that
yeah that's essentially what what I've
been afraid of and not a problem all
right thanks so much Pascal great to
hear from you great to hear from our
friendly neighbors to the north in
Canada